all right let's go to jeff
and panama city hey jeff welcome to the
dave ramsey show how can we help
well thanks for taking my call guys sure
um
i had the last two years been pretty
a whirlwind for me and
from it me and my wife have gathered up
about
25 000 dollars in credit card debt
and i was wondering is it ever a good
idea to take out a loan on a 401k
just to pay it off nope
two reasons one you unplug a good
investment
and pay yourself a lousy interest rate
and so instead of making 10 to 15 on
some good mutual funds
you're paying yourself back five or six
um
reason number two is when you leave your
company and you will leave your company
when you die
when you get a better job or when they
fire you lay you off whatever
you will leave your company when you
leave your company a 401k loan
is considered due in full within 60 days
if you do not pay it in full within 60
days you get penalized
and charged taxes a 10 penalty plus your
tax rate
and it's the last time you need a loan
coming due suddenly
when you're leaving a company and so
it's a nightmare
it sounds like it's a good idea on the
surface when you just go oh
instead of 18 on the credit card i'm
getting this and uh
and i'm paying myself interest anyway
instead of paying them interest and
uh that's how people think about it and
they get they get themselves really into
a serious pinch
what's your income jeff uh
on an average year i make about 65 to
70.
is that your household income or just
you that's just me my wife
makes another 18 to 20.
okay so you're like a 90 000 household
income
and you have twenty three thousand
dollars in credit card debt
twenty five yeah twenty five what other
debt do you have not counting your house
uh i have my cars
uh i think i owe 15 000 left on that
okay all right so 40 000
makes you debt free and you make 90 a
year
correct okay so what if we said 20 a
year
for two years that'd be kind of like
yeah not really pushing
hard on the gas at all i mean instead of
making that instead of
you know living on 90 you live on 70 and
you're debt-free in two years
so i think you ought to do it faster
well should i
lower my 401k contributions got to stop
them
can i stop them because i'm living in 25
right now doesn't matter
stop it all right and uh just
temporarily
because for the next year and a half i
want you doing nothing but paying these
debts off listing them smallest to
largest
and attacking them in that order and
you're not allowed to have a life during
that year and a half because all you're
doing is getting out of debt you got to
clean up this mess you made
no vacations no eating out you are going
to be on beans and rice rice and beans
put the cat on craigslist the dog on
ebay
yeah we've been doing that since the day
was born anyway
all right well it's time to get
somewhere with it time to get a little
traction hey i'll tell you what hang on
i'll have kelly pick up we'll put you in
ramsey plus which puts you into
financial peace university hooks up with
the every dollar budgeting app
all the ask a coach apps are in there
everything's in there to help you
and uh we'll put you in there for a year
as our gift
you had a bad year last year i want to
help you have a good year in the coming
12. hang on
we'll take care of you brother but you
got to do this stuff okay you gotta do